[Music]
[Applause]
um thank you thank you uh thanks to the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to uh to uh give this keynote uh and
also allowing me to go a bit into the
depth um so
framew framework we buil to uh simplify
building complex dashboards in Python
and I put an NX to dashboard because
actually um Solara is a web framework uh
with a focus uh towards like data apps
but data apps is not really a word many
people know uh a web app is too General
uh and we noticed that actually many
people describe what they want even
though it's not a dashboard describe it
as a dashboard so that's why the asri
um shortly about me I started as a
software engineer uh out of curiosity
went into uh astrophysics did my PhD in
postdoc and um this is what Dolly thinks
I I look like uh uh during my uh M post
when I was developing two libraries to
uh to help our group assist their work
which is f and outof coure data frame
Library um and something ipip volume
which is a 3D library for visualization
built on top of IPI
widgets and um because of this work I
became a freelancer in 2018 because
people
um really wanted to build
dashboards and so I continued working on
IPI widget became a distinguished
contributor IP Viet maintainer and
helped um co-create voila that allows
you to go from a Jupiter notebook to a
uh to a
dashboard uh continued uh development on
on facts but um basically all my clients
drove me uh towards uh creating
dashboards uh and that now led to the
company we uh we started with jti uh
co-founded that with Mario we now have a
staff of three and
growing so I want to take a little bit
of a step back why we actually write
dashboards why we write them in pure
python or want to write them in pure
Python and and what the problems are
that we encountered when writing like
more complex dashboards or web apps I'll
talk about the solutions like in the
abstract sense but I'll give Shara
examples to get a bit a more concrete
feeling what the code would look like um
as always I prefer to give a live demo
to get a bit of a feeling what it is
like to use it in practice uh after that
I can actually better describe what
salara is I want to give some examples
to show you that it's not just a hob
project that is not being used it's
really being used and um I've been blown
away by all the AI llm uh work that's
been going on over the over the last
well year or months or weeks I should
say uh and I want to talk a little bit
about the how you can integrate AI in in
web applications and
dashboards
so why do we actually do this so um
um Mo most for most reasons we we have
some data we want to get some insight we
want to share that knowledge or Insight
or it's some kind of task that we want
to automate make more efficient um
usually in like science like my
background in astronomy uh it wasn't
about money but if you if you are in
business it's usually about saving or
earning uh earning money as a next uh
step and I thought thought like what's a
concrete example of that and and
actually one of my first jobs was a um
um Al aluminum melter so they basically
produced
aluminum and um basically you have the
raw material you heat it up and then the
process becomes exothermic so you don't
have to heat it up again and they had uh
they loged all the data and they really
used like paper to lock the data and
what we built is something to like
automate that uh but it was interesting
to see like how did they work with this
data and um uh they basically looked at
the power usage and the temperature and
they actually overlaid those two graphs
hold it up to the light to see like see
through them and compare them but of
course the the the the time window was
limited by the uh armspan of the humans
holding the paper so it was not really a
sophisticated method so we automated
that made a dashboard where you can zoom
in zoom out on arbitrary time scales and
pen and they actually found out that
they could save cost uh uh quite a lot
and earned this this project back in a
short time so um just to give a concrete
example um why are we actually producing
pure python web dashboard so actually
web everything's web based now so I
don't think I I want to go into that uh
but pure python because it's actually
quite expensive to do backend and front
end development to do this separately
it's technically complex people need to
know much more than just the domain
expert that already know uh
python um and if you can stay in Python
land you can easily access all the
python libraries that are available uh
instead of having to access it via an
API so uh um much faster in development
and refactoring
as a team interchangeability if the
front end person becomes sick you can't
like continue developing so it's much
more easier if everything is in
Python uh summary easier faster
cheaper um so we helped companies build
like more complex applications or
dashboards and what are the problems
that we saw so usually it starts out as
a small
project here on the bottom bottom left
uh really small
uh limited functionality and no problems
at all but as the project started
growing actually a lot of unrelated
problems problems related to more of the
the framework that we using uh came up
and that basically made people feel like
this scrumpy
cat and what we wanted was something
where we can actually go to this more
complex applications or dashboards
without feelings like this cat and feel
more like this cat and um and I think we
succeeded in with that using using
solar um so what are the problems we
observed and I I like because I'm an I
vidget maintainer I can explicitly
mention those but there are other
Frameworks that you can fill in yourself
and I talked about this like these
problems and that's what we call
formally like incidental complexity you
adopt a framework and all of the sudden
it doesn't work the way you want and you
have to work around it and you have lots
of trouble so you want to reduce that
and you can reduce that by not spreading
your state of your application in your
UI I'm going to talk a bit about
that uh imperative like manually
creating your UI manually adding UI
elements and removing them manually
adding and removing event handlers leads
to a lot of bugs and and and difficult
to um maintain switch code and it's
really difficult if you have stayed
outside and stayed spread among your UI
elements to keep them in sync and
basically what what often happens is
your UI is in inconsistent State someone
clicks a button something doesn't update
something's not exactly
right um and especially with iPad widget
we had a trouble reusing code that's a
pretty difficult actually in uis but um
I think we have a solution to that
another thing is we if the framework was
too limited and we saw that in many
Frameworks we couldn't continue it was
just too limited didn't have these
features can you step outside
side um so yeah we felt like this for
for uh for quite some uh some projects
and I think what there's a much more
Focus uh nowadays on being developer
friendly uh what we had with IP vet like
kernel restarts that's super annoying if
you want to iterate
fast no type checking I think modern
librar should now have type checking uh
that also allows you to iterate much
faster you get feedback if you're doing
things wrong in your editor directly
when
typing uh and testing Frameworks if you
want to put something in production you
want to make sure that you have that you
can test your framework and that it
doesn't break if someone uh makes a pool
request so how do we solve
this um we actually looked at the
JavaScript World they've been building
uis for a long time really large
projects and they've been doing it quite
successful um most of them use uh or a
lot of them use reactjs so we looked at
that for inspiration
um and we looked at um an alternative to
that and a sub project signals which was
really interesting to get like um
reactivity so the main point I think of
solving this complexity in UI is your UI
should be declarative and I'm going to
go into this now reactive have some kind
of
encapsulation components that you're
able to uh use and compose and you have
to have a story for State Management in
larger application that becomes a real
problem
and hopefully feel like this
C so what is reactive uh I think most
people have in their life probably used
uh a spreadsheet or
Excel updates are always automatic the
UI always reflects the data if I change
a cell if I change so here I have length
withd and area which is just a
multiplication if I change one number
everything that depends on it will
recompute so you cannot make a mistake
you don't have to change this number and
then go through all the cells that you
want to update so how would that look in
in Python so let's assume there's a
hypothetical Library called Solara that
displays the first 20 rows in our data
frame and what we want if we say hit a
button uh trigger an event handler and
that changes the max rows that it
automatically redraws that we don't have
to think about that um but that's not
possible in Python you cannot observe
values except this person um you can
Google him on Pi data channel has some
awesome videos uh but mere mortals
cannot do this in
Python but what you can do is create
like a container for a particular value
so we have like reactive values that we
introduced in Solara and there you can
add a value property and there you can
actually observe when the value is being
read so here in the bottom we you see
that we use it so we can automatically
add event handlers and if we write it we
can trigger those event handlers so you
you don't have to think like when things
should
update so declarative tell what you want
not how to do this and uh Richie fle
already gave a a good of introduction
there this morning about the expression
system where you basically tell polers
like um I want this computation you
don't you don't say uh when you want the
filter to be applied that's something
that they can optimize for you you just
say this is the result I want and it's
up to polers on how to uh compute it um
so at home where uh we want to build a
new uh kitchen not this one but if you
want to build a kitchen you basically
want to say I want this and let the
Builder do it you don't want to say like
first do the ceiling then the uh the
floor and maybe it's like the wrong
order you don't want want to worry about
that so how does that this this concept
declarative translate to uh to a web
framework or UI framework
and idea to think about it is that your
UI is a function of your data so let's
let's make this concrete so I introduced
these reactive
variables um so we have messages which
is a reactive variable oh there
shouldn't be a DOT value here actually
and we can add to this and we can reset
it and so this is our data and we just
want to say like okay what kind of UI do
you want here so let's build this
component if the length is zero we want
to show a warning like hey there's no
messages yet and otherwise we just want
to show some information uh
component and this may seem trivial but
what you're doing you're describing what
you want based on the data but actually
underneath there's a lot of transitions
that can happen automatically in Solara
so you don't have to manually create
your UI you don't have to manually
update it if the messages change it will
update you don't have to insert new
elements and
what almost Nobody Does it just memory
leaks you don't have to manually delete
it that's something that we do you just
tell us what you
want so now I'm going to go a bit more
technical uh because um uh I think this
is a good concept to uh to Gras this
kind of like where the power is of uh of
Solara so we have a quite simple code
here we take the um unique values of a
um particular column in a data frame we
create a figure we add a barplot and we
display it using Solara we can
optionally set a title and you can
imagine having a function that dust it
that you reuse for your favorite
dashboard okay so we're going to reuse
this now I turn this into a
component by putting in this like making
it a function and giving it a
decorator and now I can reuse it so I my
my parent component makes two charts and
some other
stuff well you say well Martin what are
you doing first you're using this chem
casing why and uh isn't this just a
function and it's it's not exactly the
same so this actually makes the function
kind of lazy so when I call it here it
won't execute it I just say like I want
a bar chart here and when needed it will
execute the
function but if this reactive variable
changes this will get re-executed it
again so it will call this bar chart
function well it actually doesn't call
it I say I want this bar chart here but
it's the same one the arguments didn't
change so it will not reexecute this
function so that's the difference and I
think there's also a strong difference
between um um I think people that have
used streamlit recognize this like
re-execution but it's more like a
re-execution of the whole script and
this is on a more granular level on a
component
level
but now
um we're going to create make it a
little bit different we have an extra
argument color here and our top level
component allows us to set a color so we
have a color Pi picker so someone can
change the bar uh chart color so this
argument can change and then we need to
re-execute this so why are we actually
re-executing the whole value counts when
just the color is
changing and
and now I should come back to why the
chamel casing so the chamel casing is
actually because this component
is it's actually more like a class than
it is a function because there's a
lifetime Associated to it it doesn't
have an explicit self but kind of an
implicit self let me show you how you
can make use of this so if we reexecute
the same component instance uh a second
time with a different color we don't
want to the compu a to trigger twice and
there uh what are called hooks that
comes from the reactjs uh API we adopted
the same API as this used memo so what
you can say I want this function to be
executed if one of these dependencies
change and now it will only re-execute
if you change the color uh column not
the color so you see there's actually a
lifetime Associated to this this uh
function so when it re-execute it
actually has memory of the previous exec
execution then you say well uh I'm not
using polar so this is too uh too slow
I'm calling use memo but it takes like
two seconds to compute my UI is like not
responsive um how do I fix this there's
another like really popular uh hook in
Solara which is used thread and then
again in green showing you just the code
that is changed here uh where I said say
the same thing like execute this
function but now in a threat only when
these arguments change and you want to
of course add a progress bar and not
show the result if it's not there
yet so hopefully this communicates like
the the the idea of code reusability and
encapsulation like someone from the
outside cannot interfere this is like a
single component solving a quite complex
job
actually um
I want to talk a little bit about data
flow because I think this also really
important to to to think about like
inconsistent state so imagine we have a
dictionary containing the countries and
the cities in that country I don't know
what this middle city is but uh I don't
know where it is um so we have a
reactive variable that uh tracks which
country we selected and we can what
called two-way bind this to a select
which usually renders as a like a drop
down and you see we pass in a reactive
variable not a value but the reactive
VAR so now it's two-way bind if I change
country using a button and event handler
the select will change if I change the
select also the value change so they're
like locked
together but now I want to have a select
also for the city so what could possibly
go wrong right well actually if you if I
select einhoven I don't know where that
is in the Netherlands and I change
country to the United States all of the
sudden you see einhoven in the United
States and although you could possibly
correct it sometimes it's really
important for applications never to be
in that state never to be in an illegal
State something where maybe some query
crashes because of this combination like
einhoven in United States so you want to
step out of that you want to have like
oneway binding be able to respond to a
normal event
handler then that event handler does the
proper State Management which then
trickles down so you have this cycle of
like an event handler modifying the
state and that determining the UI and if
you if you use these patterns you'll see
that you introduce much less uh less
bugs and becomes more simple to uh to
manage okay so our ideal web framework
uh conquers complexity by having a story
about State Management how data flows
it's reactive similar to excel such that
we don't have to manually think like
okay what needs to update if uh if my
state
changes it's declarative tell what you
want so you don't have to like manually
uh update the UI encapsulation solving
complicated problems in a component and
being able to reuse those and compose
them
if the framework is too limited you want
to reach for the like the building
blocks we have that as well we were
built on top of a library so if
something is aara is not there you can
reach for the layer uh below it and you
can actually read our source code and
modify it for your own personal uh
personal use they're friendly I like hot
reloading just save and you see the
result um so today I'm not going to talk
about it but type checking and testing
is also quite important so uh this is
our ideal framework work and people
who've seen a talk of me probably
recognize this slide has always worked
so let's see if it works
now
okay so we run uh we have a script we
run Solara run what's it
called
no
worries it complains no object with name
page found so every application should
start with
a it's much easier now with co-pilot
actually no not not not yet not
yet
uh so because we're kind of have a
Jupiter uh back background like
everything that you can display in
Jupiter you can also display in
Solara so I I take this crime data set
from s Francisco and display it as I
could display in a jupyter notebook
using the same protocols and what we're
going to take a look at this this
category I don't like this uh full caps
so let's
see
no
is it this one yeah okay um and I showed
you in the slides this uh this uh to to
produce this bar chart I put this in the
in the code here so it's already
prepared so we could
do uh bar
charts almost
almost
uh I think we don't have to give a title
okay so every time a shave it it like
re-executes um maybe it's also useful oh
to not
touch yeah uh maybe we want to limit it
to particular categories because we
can't read this so again we start with
first like the data what do we want to
store
um per
okay thank you
co-pilot and then we probably want to
filter this
[Music]
so almost do
value someone see the
problem sorry
they
have this you mean yeah I mean I I could
do this but I think the error is is
different I want to keep the
original
ah I mean perfect audience for this
right
okay uh so now we have our filter data
frame we want to use it to like uh to
control what the categories
are um let's put in a
sidebar uh
select
is it correct
unique probably to
list okay I'm going to cheat a little
bit co-pilot is not working with me
today get this out of the way so we have
uh um
values
okay so now if I
change
this it doesn't
work
where ah because I only give it this one
so it's not bir directional and now we
can actually like change this
I just showed you the this more
complicated one with the
threads is it this one so now we can
actually have a progress bar so every
time this changes we see a progress bar
doing the computation and then showing
it when it's ready okay just to give a
bit of a feeling what this uh this uh
looks like okay so maybe you have some
colleagues that actually prefer working
in a Jupiter notebook because we built
this on top of the IPI vidget and
Jupiter stack we can actually run this
perfectly fine in the jupyter notebook
the only thing different is the sidebar
there's no really a place for it so it's
like listed here but you can run it full
screen if uh if needed so that allows
you to experiment in the Jupiter
notebook and what's also interesting
because of these reactive
variables uh so so what did we do
categories reactive value we can
actually mutate or
change the uh the value it
has from the UI or from a notebook
cell and it will trigger the computation
so also in the notebook this is really
good way of exploring your data
you reactive variables can be read out
and WR from the Jupiter
notebook uh and as I
said no I'm going to skip that FCO
doesn't
work okay so I think now we are in a
better position to describe a bit what
Solara
is so what you saw mostly is the UI part
so that's a pure uh python web framework
to build like apps or dashboards I uh it
has a react like API
plus the reactive variables uh which
reduce complexity of your application
you have to think less declarative you
just describe in all the transitions
they go automatically like adding and
removing elements it's composable so I
produced this like bar uh bar chart
component with threading that I can
easily add put into my library of
favorite like components and reuse in
your company uh over and over again uh
Solara has a lot of built-in
components things like buttons sliders
you saw some of them um m m plot lip
support of course data frame support and
it's built on top of the IPI widget
ecosystem so you can actually drill down
to the underlying libraries and
customize things if you if you uh if you
need to but it also solves like common
data science uh challenges like
threading as I said like the use thread
hook cross filtering and caching are a
really common
task um and the uh State Management
Library we rebuild in top of it this
type save and gives this reactive uh
part something I didn't talk much about
but I was using dup to notebook but we
also have the Solara server and that's
an really efficient server using stot F
or fast API I I'll talk a bit more about
this in this slide so to give a bit of
an idea of this like how is it built how
does it fit into the whole stack so the
UI
part um is basically the Solara
components are built using reacton which
is a react like library in Python um
that's built on top of IPI
widgets and using the iPad FY material
design component that gives this like
more modern look and feel all of this
runs in like Jupiter notebook uh Jupiter
lab voila but also online on Co collab
um but I also showed you the Solara
server so it's using fast API for the
web server and the websocket or Starlet
um but still using the same protocols so
we reuse the protocols that the browser
talks to with normally with the Jupiter
stack we we reuse those same
protocols but the main difference
between uh like running Solara and
production is like the efficiency like
uh uh in Jupiter every user would have
their own process well here it's it's um
we produce what's what we call virtual
kernels so are people using this like
what can you build I gave you a really
small view of what you can build on the
solaro website we have some like simple
examples to get you started slightly
more advanced examples uh but it's
always difficult to give a really
complex problem and and it's it's really
hard to digest this so here's an example
where you can upload the data set choose
the columns uh draw a selection and just
download that
part there's a uh project called glue uh
a project started at Harvard um and they
used QT so that was a desktop
application they want to go to the web
and we're using Solara for that you see
the uh connection still with astronomy
here showing up nice image of the sky uh
but it allows you to make really
complicated uh link data sets where you
select something and data set show show
this selection in in um in other
plot there's a company in Switzerland
called Plano that uh started with a
prototype in a Jupiter uh Jupiter
notebook and that's now uh a real
product um they use Solara server and
turning more of the code also to the
Solara components um and they use this
application and mostly with the the
drawing on the map to uh plan District
Heating and and Cooling
uh we're running a uh like mentorship
program actually this this week and uh
was pretty nice to see this example of a
uh live dashboard so this is showing
like these values getting them from from
an exchange and updating them when the
value changes there something that is
sometimes people ask like how how can I
do that but it it it's like almost
trivial it's because you work on the
python side you just ask the data set
the value and it will be synchronized in
the in the UI
so a lot of
um UI I think in the in the future will
need to be able to do something with
llms and with that I'm I'm talking
Beyond a cat gbt clone I think this is
something that many people want to build
is like a modern hello world like okay I
want to write my own chatbot um and
actually we're going to release these
chat components uh uh uh hopefully uh
tomorrow so you can actually build those
but I think it's more they more
interesting things you can build and
something that really triggered us was
the uh during the open AI uh death day
this wonderlust
application uh this was not available
the source code so we actually produced
our own uh variant of that and the idea
is is that you yes you can chat with an
llm but you can actually also let it
call functions on your side so let's um
in this uh example we give it two
functions a function to zoom in on the
map on a particular location and uh a
function to put a marker at a particular
location so let's see it's always
different how it works where do you want
to go I want to go to H
Hoven so then the llm can actually say
like okay zoom into this location this
zoom level
um and you can ask it to give you
particular locations that could be uh
could be interesting it's always a
surprise what it comes up with it
probably hallucinates some locations
phip Museum
Etc would you
like usually it does it by itself but
sometimes it needs some uh
convincing I don't think it's going to
do that today
yeah and I think this is this is a
simple concept maybe not so useful but
the idea of of being able to talk to an
llm and being able to execute tasks I
think it's it's really interesting
concept and another example that
afterwards what what we came up with is
this Glo project that I described uh
before you can actually also do some
really interesting things with uh with
without chat so this glue um program
allows you to link data sets so you need
to say like this column is equal to this
column and humans need to do
this
and if your domain expert in this case
astronomy you recognize oh of course
right ensan belongs to ra
j2000 right we all know that and
declination belongs to
dj200 I mean an llm will totally
understand that but that's something we
need to do manually and if you have 10
of these data set you have to do that
for many many columns and many data sets
basically map these to each other
perfect t for an llm has all this domain
knowledge so you basically send to the
chatbot these are my columns these are
the functions to link them do your best
and actually it will uh in this case
make suggestions you can uh afterwards
like check what you want and then like
automate these and I think this is a
really nice example of how you can use
an llm to to to automate some of your
task in dashboards or web
apps so Solara is open source we have an
open source Community it's it's MIT
licensed we do regular updates hope to
do an uh release tomorrow um it's
growing fast um also GitHub stars are
trending nicely um you can join us on
Discord or GitHub for Community
Support yes spelled correctly and and
something interesting what we're doing
right now is a a mentorship program
where people uh work in groups uh to
solve particular task with with Solara
and we help them like reach that goal
it's a really interesting way of
interacting with the community they get
to learn like how to how um Works while
we get to see all the rough edges that
we need to uh to
polish uh doing that in combination with
plumer uh I'm not going to read all of
this uh we are a company so we have some
commercial support as well but I'll
leave this uh for now so just to
summarize so hopefully I convince you
that that Solara simplifies building
more complex dashboards in Python it's a
modern python web framework it pushes
the boundary
of the size of apps or dashboards that
you can build and it enables like domain
expert to write larger applications in
100% python without having to modify or
without having to go to like separate
front end back end
teams we think this is a uh to adopt is
like L low risk because we're using
proven technology like react the API is
expressive enough in JavaScript so why
not in Python uh and we're using proven
Technologies such as iPad widget Jupiter
and fast API we have an open source
Community if you need help um if needed
we have Professional Services and uh
hopefully Solara will lead to less of
this and uh more of this thank
[Applause]
you all right Martin thank you for the
Fantastic talk
and I think we have about 5 minutes now
for some
questions got a dice coming at
you I speak like this in the yeah okay
uh how do you compare Solara with stream
[Laughter]
L yeah I I I person I don't like uh
comparisons uh because I'm I'm biased so
disclaimer I'm
biased uh but it's also fair to
recognize like where streamlets purposes
and where solara's purposes and we get
this question a lot
so um both of them are declarative so
streamlit is also declarative you
basically say what you want and it will
reexecute and it will update what's
needed stream lit is very simple like
simpler than Solara
although um Solara I think also in
simple cases is is quite simple but
slightly steeper learning curve
especially if you want to do the more
advanced things like working with
threads um and other
hooks
um in stream L is actually difficult you
can write front end components but you
cannot easily write backend components
in python as Le I mean I've never seen
example of that Solara it's the default
everything you write is reusable by
default uh streamlit has state in UI
Solara we chose not to have this in the
UI because the UI there's not not always
a onetoone mapping between uh between
those um we support bir directional
communication on
everything um so you can have like
events multiple events you could have
like 10 maybe events like selecting
something clicking on the plot and I
think that's one of the uh weaknesses of
of streamlit that they usually get like
one
output um we don't try to hide the CSS
so if you have a front front Ed person
that can help you make something nice we
have um you can put this person to use
to uh to customize it um I think
streamlit is is main purpose is smaller
scrips uh difficult to scale Beyond like
a single page I mean they they have it
but it become if talk to each other
becomes more complex well that that's
kind of the default uh and we have a
tutorial especially for people coming
from
streamlet okay any other questions maybe
one that wasn't a plant in the audience
it wasn't planned expected anticipated
yeah
yeah it is oh yeah okay was already
anxiously looking around where to expect
it from um yeah so uh for a lot of hobby
projects I think it's fairly interesting
to be able to provide visualizations to
people in their browser but that you
don't want to go through the effort of
running a server uh as well uh is that
something that that you can do with
Solara easily for example with py script
uh or or do you always need a server uh
still
running um something went wrong here
I'll try to answer um we can execute in
a
browser but not with standard standard
py script or pite we have our own own
views on how that how that should work
uh I think if you follow me on Twitter
you should within a few months you
should see something on that on that uh
topic and I should leave it to that
actually but technically possible uh
technically possible uh uh I I could
show you how how it works but not
something I want to publicly say
something about yet okay fair enough
thanks
yeah
anyone you
just do you have a similar comparison uh
of Solara with dash
dash
uh we do have a tutorial for people
coming from
Dash that's great yeah the the the main
point of that tutorial is that in in
dash although technically it's possible
to create a reusable
component um it uh probably doesn't fit
on my screen that's kind of the the I
think Dash is more uh for solving a
particular
problem um but not some something where
it's easy to write something that you
can reuse in multiple places there it
doesn't really shine I would say um okay
thanks maybe useful to take a look at
the torial that gives concrete examples
yeah
thanks okay well let's thank Martin for
the talk thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
am